et comment vous voyez-vous aujourd'hui, qu'est
-ce que ça fait d'être un Bob Dylan en 1984,
tout comme 66 peut être exactement la même euh un
peu la même ouais peut-elle être juste un
peu plus explicite à ce sujet eh bien
vous serez plus expérimenté ici  plus d'
expérience, donc quelles que soient vos expériences,
c'est qui vous êtes qui
aimez-vous travaillait dans le
domaine du chanteur / compositeur aujourd'hui qui j'aime
j'étais un groupe de gens Tom Waits est
plutôt bon
John's à Richmond ici
ouais il est plutôt bon
il y a ce gars qui parle toujours
de toi, tu manques Costello
Elvis aux coutumes il est plutôt bon
tu aimes les séries ouais comme tous les jours
écris le livre
dans les années 60 et les années 70 Superstars où des
gens comme toi Lennon vont nous en prison
aujourd'hui il semble que ce soit plus de gens comme
Michael Jackson voyez-vous une différence
de qualité ou dans ce que les gens exigent ou
attendent d'une star de la musique eh bien
oui vous devez vous devez faire de nouvelles
vidéos passionnantes c'est la grande
différence
ou pour votre carrière vous avez toujours sh  posséder un
fort sens de l'humour mélangé à de l'
insolence et du manque de respect est-il plus amusant
d'être insolent quand vous étiez enfant en
commençant là où vous étiez une
institution mondialement connue sur vous toujours une institution ouais
plus facile mais toujours pas si difficile
quand l'avez-vous préféré à votre
débuts ou 2012 quand était-ce beaucoup plus
drôle pour toi plus drôle ouais ça a
toujours été drôle
c'est toujours ouais ouais qu'est-ce que tu ressens
le plus ces jours-ci mais Garrett
ou Billy the Kid non ne dis pas oui non
eh bien tu sais ils  à la fois le même homme a fait
le fait que les gens vous appellent un génie
ont une influence sur votre écriture eh bien
c'est difficile d'être appelé le génie que vous
connaissez
pas de problème est-ce que vous commencez à le
croire elle le voit dans le journal
vous intensifiez le génie ici  tu dois être comment
ça se passe comment j'agis maintenant
mais je n'ai jamais cru
que tu avais le même besoin débordant
d'écrire aujourd'hui qu'aujourd'hui quand tu as
dit si je n'écrivais pas un bon fou ouais
ouais pratiquer les ramen se coucherait et
allongé essayant d'aller s  leep des pensées te
passent par la tête tu sais te lever
écris dans tous les cas tu prends toujours
le même plaisir à travailler sans
écrire tu vois j'écris parce que j'ai besoin de
quelque chose de pareil
parfois c'est affiché c'est douloureux
tu sais tu es debout des jours des nuits à te promener
essayez de finir ceci ou faites cela obtenir ce
droit obtenir cette ligne
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas ça il n'y avait pas d'
écoles c'est toujours de haut en bas
comment expliquez-vous le fait que depuis
le début le français a toujours été
phonétiquement et flou un bâton sur le
mots à vos chansons alors qu'ils
ont généralement la répétition pour ne pas avoir de travail
dans les chansons anglaises et américaines, j'ai
étudié beaucoup de poètes français probablement
quand j'étais, vous savez, j'ai commencé sur
leurs plus grands gars,
mais il y avait une appréciation
je pense que c'est peut-être à cause de la
marque laissée par votre surréalisme
concentration de poésie française ouais
probablement je veux dire je viens d'arriver en dernier vous
savez ce qui s'est passé vous venez de
prendre ce que la dernière chose était ju  st est
venu à cette période existentielle
à cette fin
étiez-vous au courant de cette ArrayList quand
vous quand vous avez commencé à écrire je n'étais pas au
courant jusqu'à ce que je sois vous y avez dérivé
assez naturellement est sorti de la grande boîte
puis a dérivé dans  ces
poètes surréalistes mais j'ai fait ça naturellement je n'ai pas
dit que tu sais que je vais faire ça
pour arriver si tu as senti des changements des
changements tu sais dans tes
techniques d'écriture et donc à quelles périodes
je pense que j'ai changé à la fin des années 60
et j'ai changé  probablement encore fin des années 70
je savais attention trop tard dans les années 80 je
ne pense pas donc je ne pense pas
j'espère mais je ne suis pas sûr que vous puissiez plus
vous lasser de changer cela pendant un
moment vous êtes à court de moyens rapides dans
Bande dessinée française je ne savais pas je ne sais pas
si vous le saviez prendriez vous ça
comme un compliment monsieur
dee dee
dee beaucoup de choses vous savez la vie comme ça
que pensez vous de la façon dont les
jeunes pourraient percevoir  de la musique à
travers des clips vidéo et bien ça fait sens
qu'il vend des disques mais alors un  dans un autre sens, les
gens considèrent probablement la maison et voient
la personne chanter pourquoi sortiraient-ils
pour les voir, vous savez qu'ils ne vont
pas être aussi beaux si quand ils vont les voir
aujourd'hui, ils vont les voir transpirer
ils vont voir  sous différents angles,
ils vont voir beaucoup de choses
qu'ils ne voient pas sur une vidéo, donc vous ne pouvez pas
être si jolie en
utilisant des looks assainis
en réalité ce n'est jamais comme ça
d'ailleurs était une belle blonde dans
ce sans vidéo  était accro ou
solo c'était micktaylor mais non non ou nous
changeons notre blonde
je ne sais pas tellement d'autres et ils
vont et viennent tout le temps je ne sais pas
vous êtes-vous senti affecté d'une quelconque façon par ce qui
s'est passé dans  L'Irak à partir de 77 ou
pensez-vous qu'il y a un lien entre ce qui
se passe dans la musique rock au Royaume-Uni et en
Amérique à la fin des années 70 oui, je suis connu
pour ne rien porter signalé ayant les
lumières et les bases, alors peut-être que The Clash Sex
Pistols en
dehors de cela  Je ne peux rien penser de bien
tu sais en Europe ça commençait  g d'un
nouveau nouveau mouvement inna dans la musique rock ouais
ouais c'était très important
un autre tu ne ressens pas la même chose tu connais
les taux d'intérêt je ne pense pas donc
ça fait un bon moment que nous n'avons pas eu
une chanson en colère de toi la dernière  eh bien, le
dernier était peut-être un ouragan dans cette région
ou diriez-vous une baie de quartier sur
un infidèle allez-vous porter la colère jusqu'à
présent, les
fils pas en colère peuvent être conçus comme
un équilibre d'amour mélodique très doux,
cela pourrait être très en colère
sous ceux-
ci c'est la preuve  que quel que soit le style de
musique que vous jouez, votre goût est pour la
musique vraie et vraie musique qui ne fait pas de
compromis appliqueriez-vous la
définition à quiconque joue aujourd'hui
ouais les gens que j'ai fait j'avais mentionné
généralement oui un auteur-compositeur-interprète
qui  se produit tout seul, c'est beaucoup plus facile
pour lui de le faire que si
quelqu'un est dans un groupe ou un groupe pour le faire
parce que c'est un chanteur, une seule
personne peut le faire par lui-même, il peut
faire tout ce qu'il veut par lui-même
ne  pas besoin de  ça ne doit pas
être démocratique voter Leon quelle
direction tu vas prendre ici
et c'est très c'est très rare de
trouver un groupe qui réfléchit tous ensemble qui
sont tous compétents confiants dans ce
qu'ils font quels sont vos projets  pour
toi lors de ton prochain rappel j'ai entendu dire que ça pourrait
être acoustique eh bien je vais faire
quelques trucs acoustiques je pense ouais ouais
pas toute une semaine oh je ne pense pas et
tu arrives à trois chansons avec l'
harmonica de guitare
est là  tout ce dont tu rêvais
quand tu étais enfant et que tu n'as
pas pu réaliser malgré le
fait que ton corps s'est épuisé parce que tu étais
devenu Bob Dylan
oh on va à Disneyland
je ne pense pas à ça
en 16  et 1963 vous avez écrit la moitié de cette forte
pluie va tomber pensez-vous qu'un
jour cela pourrait enfin se former et sinon
que vous voyez-vous dans dix ans à
partir de maintenant et je ne me voyais pas maintenant
il y a dix ans
maintenant
vous pouvez voir où d'autres  les gens vont
être dans dix ans à partir de maintenant que toi  f
est difficile à voir
et que dire de la pluie et du départ dans le
dossier
merci merci beaucoup